This cellphone started its trajectory in an artisanal mine in the Eastern Congo.
It's mined by armed gangs using child slaves, what the UN Security Council calls "blood minerals"...
...then traveled into some components and ended up in a factory in Xinjin in China.
In that factory, over a dozen people have committed suicide already this year.
One man died after working a 36 - hour shift.
We all love chocolate. We buy it for our kids.
80 percent of the cocoa comes from Cote d'Ivoire and Ghana and it's harvested by children.
In Cote d'Ivoire, we have a huge problem of child slaves.
Children have been trafficked from other conflict zones to come and work on the coffee plantations.
Heparin: blood thinner, a pharmaceutical product starts out in artisanal workshops like this in China...
...because the active ingredient comes from pigs' intestines.
Your diamond; you've all heard, probably seen the movie "Blood Diamond".
This is a mine in Zimbabwe right now. Cotton: Uzbekistan is the second biggest exporter of cotton on Earth.
Every year when it comes to the cotton harvest, the government shuts down the schools, puts the kids in buses,...
...buses them to the cotton fields to spend three weeks harvesting the cotton.
It's forced child labor on an institutional scale.
And all of those products probably end their lives in a dump like this one in Manila.
These places, these origins, represent governance gaps.
That's the politest description I have for them.
These are the dark pools where global supply chains begin,...
...the global supply chains which bring us our favorite brand name products.
Some of these governance gaps are run by rogue states.
Some of them are not states anymore at all; they're failed states.
Some of them are just...
...countries who believe that deregulation or no regulation is the best way to attract investment,...
...to promote trade.